have you noticed that your favorite dish
at your local restaurant is a little
small or that there don't seem to be
quite as many cookies in a packet you
may be experiencing shrink inflation
when sellers respond to inflation not by
raising prices but cutting costs seems
like everyone's doing it a small box of
Kleenex has gone from 65 tissues to 60.
a party-sized bag of Frito Scoops went
from 18 ounces to 15 and a half when it
comes to snacks inflation imposed
downsizing might be good for your health
but what's definitely not is
shrinkflation's scarier cousin skin
deflation the term was coined by NPR's
Planet Money to describe when companies
start substituting cheaper ingredients
in their products if you examine the
nutrition labels in your shopping cart
you might notice more sugars sodium and
natural flavorings than before skim
flation doesn't just refer to food
Electronics might be made with cheaper
parts and there is noticeably less
service at restaurants bars and hotels
for the same price of course